>> Greg: IT SHALL BE NOTED
JOE GOT COVID.
ALMOST A RHYME THE WHITE HOUSE
REVEALED THE PRESIDENT HAS COVID
AND IS EXPERIENCING MILD
SYMPTOMS INCLUDING CHILLS,
SNIFFLES, NOT KNOWING WHO HE IS.
[LAUGHTER]
IN OTHER WORDS, NOTHING HAS
CHANGED.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY SAID
FOR NOW HE WILL WORK IN
ISOLATION WHICH SHOULD BE EASY
CONSIDERING THAT'S HOW HE SPENT
HIS CAMPAIGN.
BIDEN SHOULD RECOVER FROM COVID
BUT WITH FRIENDS LIKE THESE, HIS
REELECTION PLANS ARE CLEARLY
DOA.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN HELD A
CONTROVERSIAL MEETING WITH THE
CROWN PRINCE OF SAUDI ARABIA.
>> BIDEN SAID IT WASN'T OF HIS
PALM, THAT WAS ME TRYING TO
PUNCH HIM AS HARD AS I CAN.
>> HE 79, MAYBE THAT'S HOW HARD
YOU CAN PUNCH.
>> STOP ASKING HIM ABOUT THE
FIST BUMP, ASK HIM ABOUT THE
LOOMING RECESSION.
>> I THAT DR. FAUCI SAYS HE
PLANS TO RETIRE AT THE END OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S TERM.
>> ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE TOO?
>> Greg: BETTER LATE THAN EVER
MY GUYS.
EVEN THOUGH THE JOKES WERE AS
TOOTHLESS AS JOE BIDEN HIMSELF.
A FLING LIKE RATS FROM THE
TITANIC AND YOU SHOULD KNOW HE
WAS ON BOARD THAT DISASTER AS
WELL.
OFFICIALS UNVEILED THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S SAFER AMERICAN PLAN
OR SAP, A MASSIVE REFUNDING OF
THE POLICE.
AT THE PARTY THAT WAS ALL ABOUT
DEFUNDING WANTS TO SPEND
$37 BILLION ON CRIME PREVENTION.
BIDEN'S BOLDEST MOVE ON PAPER.
THE PROPOSED PLAN WOULD HELP
HIRE AND TRAIN AN ADDITIONAL
100,000 COPS, INVEST $3 BILLION
TO CLEAR COURT BACKLOGS AND
ANOTHER $5 BILLION IN COMMUNITY
A VIOLENT INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
IF A OCS PROVISION FOR THOUSANDS
OF INVISIBLE HANDCUFFS.
YES.
SO, THE DEMS ARE NOW PRETENDING
TO BE PRO-COP WHEN THEY'RE
TRYING TO PREPARE WHAT THEY
DESTROYED WHEN THEY WERE
ANTI-COP.
OR MAYBE THEY ARE TRYING TO HELP
CORI BUSH SAVE MONEY ON PRIVATE
SECURITY.
BUT MAYBE THEY'RE DOING IT TO
SAVE THEIR OWN.
IMAGINE DEALING WITH SOMEBODY
WHO DESTROYS THINGS IN ORDER TO
FIX IT.
>> CAN I SEE?
>> SURE.
>> WOW.
YOU KNOW THESE ARE BROKEN?
>> YOU RUINED THEM!
>> LET'S NOT PLAY THE BLAME
GAME.
I CAN FIX IT IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
>> THERE YOU GO!
YOU'RE WELCOME!
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THOSE TWO PAIRS OF
SUNGLASSES FOR THE SKIT CAME OUT
OF OUR BUDGET.
>> THAT'S HOW FAR BUDGET.
>> Greg: DO YOU CARE TO
COMMENT ON THE BREAKING NEWS OF
COVID OR THE POLICE?
>> I KNOW, IT'S JUST ALL THIS --
>> Greg: NO MORE MULTIPLE
CHOICES OKAY?
>> NO, I JUST CAN'T GET OVER HOW
WE TALK ABOUT THIS NEW STUFF
LIKE THE WHOLE OIL CANCER THING
DIDN'T HAPPEN YESTERDAY.
I CAN'T GET OVER AT!
HE SAID I HAVE CANCER FROM OIL
ON MY MOM'S WINDSHIELD!
70 YEARS AGO!
SKIN CANCER TOO.
LIKE NO, LIKE SOME SKIN
CANCER -- THAT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE
TO WHAT HE SAID!
LIKE AM I THE ONLY ONE THAT IS
STILL THINKING ABOUT THIS?
>> Greg: THE MAYBE THAT'S WHY
THEY ANNOUNCED COVID.
>> THIS ARTICLE AND LOOKING IT
UP IN PEOPLE WROTE -- JOE BIDEN
SAID HE WAS AFFECTED BY CANCER.
HE DID NOT SAY THAT!
HE SAID I HAVE OIL CANCER!
[LAUGHTER]
TO ME, I THINK IT'S A REALLY BIG
SIGN OF HOW CRAZY THINGS HAVE
GOTTEN WHEN I LOOKED AT TWITTER
FOR HOURS LAST NIGHT ABOUT THE
OIL CANCER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE DOES HE
HAVE CANCER OR NOT?
HOW CRAZY IS IT THE PRESIDENT'S
LIKE I HAVE CANCER AND WE'RE
LIKE WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
OTHER PEOPLE WERE LIKE
REGARDLESS OF YOUR POLITICAL
VALUES, WE HAVE TO AGREE THAT
CANCER IS THE SCARIEST THINGS
AND THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS TO
BIDEN'S OIL CANCER.
>> Greg: SHE WENT WITH CHOOSE
YOUR OWN ADVENTURE.
>> I'M NOT WILLING TO MOVE ON
FROM THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF OIL
CANCER!
AND BEING GHASTLY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT I SHOULD NOT
BE HAVING THIS TYPE OF REACTION.
>> Greg: IT'S A FAIR POINT
BECAUSE IF TRUMP SAID ANYTHING
LIKE THAT, COULD YOU IMAGINE THE
INTERPRETATIONS?
>> IF I SENT ANYTHING LIKE THAT!
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
YOU OKAY NOW, KIDDO?
SPEAK OUT I SAY
>> IF I SAY I HAVECANCER, I
WILL.
>> Greg: YOU REALLY ARE A DARK
HUMAN BEING.
FAIRLY BIG NEWS, DO YOU THINK IT
WILL AFFECT HIS JOB?
>> AT THIS POINT IT CAN ONLY
IMPROVE HIS PERFORMANCE.
I THINK HE SHOULD TURN HIMSELF
OVER TO THE VIRUS.
I THINK YOU'LL BE A TOUGH ONE TO
BRING DOWN.
HE BEAT THE 1918 FLU, THAT
DIDN'T STOP HIM.
KAT MENTIONED, HE KICKED CANCER
IN 24 HOURS.
THAT'S UNHEARD OF.
HE'S GOT THE BEST PEOPLE AROUND
HIM TAKING CARE OF HIM.
NICE HOT BOWL OF SOUP.
LOOK AT THE IMMUNE SYSTEM, LOOK
AT HIS SON HUNTER.
I BET IF YOU PUT A ON HUNTER, IT
WOULD INFLATE LIKE A BALLOON
ANIMAL WITH THE POWER AND HIM.
HE'S GOING TO BE FINE.
COUNTRIES IN A LOT OF TROUBLE,
BUT JOE'S GOING TO BE FINE.
>> THE OTHER THING TOO, KAT,
YOU'RE LUCKY TO BE MARRIED TO A
DOCTOR.
>> THAT'S WHY HE GOT CURED SO
FAST.
SHE WAS LIKE READING IT FROM ONE
OF HER BOOKS.
I'LL COMMENT ON THE POLICE.
I'LL TAKE IT AS A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR.
COPS, NO-BRAINER.
THEY'VE BEEN DEFUNDING THEM SO
MUCH THEY MAY KNOW SET UP A
PROGRAM THAT DOES NOTHING.
A PRINCE MONEY TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT
NOW WE HAVE FAKE MONEY IN
BALLOONS GOING UP IN SMOKE AND
JUST SAYING THAT YOU'RE
ATTACKING A PROBLEM THAT YOU
CREATED BY NOT --
>> Greg: I DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT.
WHICH IS THE MONEY GO?
>> YOU HAVE TO APPLY FOR A GIANT
GRANT, YOU HAVE TO PAY LOBBYISTS
AND GO TO DOJ, MAKE THEM DID NOT
INVESTIGATE HUNTER BIDEN, THEN
YOU GET $100 BILLION IN RETURN.
IT'S A TOTAL [BLEEP] SCAM.
>> Greg: I WOULD DO THAT FOR
THAT MONEY.
I'M NOT EVEN -- I'M NOT -- I'M
NOT SURE WHAT HE IS AT THIS
POINT.
AS A PROFESSION.
>> I DON'T REALLY KNOW IT
EITHER.
THAT'S WHY YOU CAN CHARGE SO
MUCH.
>> Greg: JULIE, YOU ARE THE
FACE OF NEWS HERE.
>> THAT'S WHY I THINK I SHOULD
ADDRESS THE NEWS WE ARE KNOCKINT
TESTING ABOUT JILL BIDEN.
SHE TESTED NEGATIVE, GOOD FOR
HER, THANK GOD.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS, AS A SPOUSE
OF A HUSBAND WHO FORMERLY HAD
COVID, I'VE GOT ADVICE FOR HER.
RUN LIKE.
OF WHILE THE COVID VARIANT IS
LIKE A COLD FOR A FEMALE, IT'S
INSUFFERABLE MAN SLAYER.
IF IN I HAD A TRIP PLANNED AND
IN THE MORNING OF THE FLIGHT,
GUESS WHAT?
THE HUSBAND TESTED FOR COVID AND
HE WAS POSITIVE.
HE WENT TO THE AIRPORT AND I
HEADED OUT.
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY
FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING RESPONSES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS WHEN I SAY
AND THAT'S WAY BACK IN APRIL.
UNDO IT FOR A NEW VACATION
>> Greg: MONKEYPOX, ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S FUNNY.
OH,